we have more the nominees for original  song and scored and adaptation are panty  adapter scores are Alfred  one from the heart song score by Charlie  victor/victoria song score by relevancy  the winner is henry mancini  and Leslie Lucas convicted Korea  it's been a while he doesn't say you  know thank you Academy and special  thanks to Jenny and my lovely family and  special special thanks for the beautiful  25 years between Peter Gunn and  victor/victoria to Blake Edwards  I'd like to thank mr. and mrs. Edwards  Blake and Julie and all the wonderful  people around you especially my friend  there  Henry Henrietta Thank You Academy Evie  for you